this is session five the foundations of
Finance module and in this session we
want to build on the concept of risk by
going from risk aversion which is what
we talked about in the last session two
measures of risk let's first talk about
why we spent so much time on the
question of whether investors and human
beings would risk of us if we were all
risk neutral we collectively as human
beings we would accept the risk free
rate as our expected return on every
investment no matter how risky it is
since we are risk averse we will pay
less for a risky expected - cash flow
than an otherwise equivalent guaranteed
cash flow so the question at risk of
converting risk aversion to value then
becomes how do we bring that measure of
the how do we measure risk and then how
do we bring that risk measure into our
assessment of value so that we can
reduce the value of more risky Azam
that's a challenge I'd like to deal with
in this session the framework that
drives much of what we think about
finance about risk in finance is the
mean variance frame and in the mean
variance framework here's what we do as
investors we assume that the expected
return on investment is the plus and
that we measure the risk in an
investment by the variance in returns on
an investment you see what are you
talking about when you invested in in in
any asset and a business there is an
expected return your actual return so
can be different from those expected
returns that is risk so if you have a
risk-free investment you're essentially
telling me that your expected return and
your actual return are always the same
in other words your actual return is
exactly your expected return that's a
risky investment a risky investment in
the mean Bering's framework is one where
the actual returns are different from
the expected return and the more
different they are the riskier
investment becomes you see that sounds
pretty intuitive so what's the big deal
here's the big deal in the mean variance
framework we are assuming that the only
two things you care about as an investor
is expected return as you good and
variance as you bet for that to be true
one of two things has to be true one is
that returns are normally distributed
know what I mean by normally distributed
rights it's a symmetric distribution the
great thing about the normal
distribution is can be described with
two parameters the expected return and
the standard deviation I mean variable
the other is is you have a u-turn a
function remember we talked about you
turn a functions as being the engines
that drive risk-aversion
yummy eternity function that leads you
to care only about expected return and
standard deviation there are some
utility functions that allow it they're
very strange of dirty functions but one
of those two things has to be in place
for you to bind to the mean variance
framework so what I'm admitting to
upfront is the entire framework is a
little shaky because it's built on this
presumption that all you care about is
expect a return as you could and
standard deviations let's with Slash
variance as you're back now having said
that though when you think about
investing in a business and you think
about where the variance in actual
returns is coming from in that business
you can trace that variance to lots of
different fundamentals it could be
because individual investments that this
company has taken have not generated the
returns you'd expect so if you're
investing in a retail company an
individual store they might open up my
not do as well about as well as the
expect or might do much better than
expected think of that as project
specific risk investments you take as a
company not delivering exactly what you
expected and remember again risk can be
both upside and downside it could be
that you're in a business where you
you're doing exactly what you expect to
do but your competition is acting
differently maybe they're stronger or
weaker than expected that could affect
your returns it could be also that the
entire sector is being affected by a law
that's been passed taxes that drive your
sector so it's not just you but it's the
entire sector all of the companies in
your sector it could be a risk that
affects you know more than just your
sector it could be just the dollar gets
stronger or weaker that could affect not
just your sector but all sectors that
are exposed to exchange rate risk or
finally it could be the entire you know
it could be interest rates changing the
economy becoming stronger or we
in which case it's not just your
company's every company in the market he
said why separate risk into these groups
in a sense what I've done is have broken
risk down and ERISA defects one or a few
companies risk that affects most or all
companies that is going to be my
starting point for why diversification
pays off for investors because when you
spread your beds across investments
here's what's going to happen the risk
that affects most roll companies
interest rate risks big macroeconomic
risk is still going to be that you
cannot eliminate that risk by holding a
hundred stocks but the risk of affects
one or a few companies is going to
average out think of what it's a law of
large numbers so if you own a hundred
companies for every company where a
project does better than expect another
one a project could do worse than
expected that risks averaged out the
argument for diversification is a pretty
intuitive one which is as you spread
across investments your exposure to that
firm specific risk is going to get
smaller because you're getting the law
of large numbers working in your favor
in fact there are two ways you can argue
for wide diversification reduces your
exposure to firm specific risk the
weaker argument is hey every investment
is now just a smaller part of my overall
portfolio so I don't feel the pain as
much why is that weaker because you
still feel the pain the much stronger
argument though is the one that I just
gave because as you spread across
multiple companies risk that affects one
or a few companies is going to average
out since not just that you feel less
pain you might not feel the pain at all
because it averages out across your
portfolio so the argument for
diversification is a simple one but it
can be made statistical and there is an
there is a benefit looking at the
statistical basis for diversification so
let's take an example let's suppose you
have two stocks stock one has a lower
expected return and a lower standard
deviation 1.5% expected return 10%
standard deviation stock - as a higher
expected return a higher standard
deviation if you lived in a mean
variance word and you could pick only
one stock and you were risk averse you'd
pick stock one because it's less risky
but let's assume that stock one and
stock two don't know
move together and I'm going to capture
that with a correlation the correlation
kept us how stock 1 and stock do move
together and that correlation is only
point tool if you're not familiar with
correlations correlations range from
minus 1 to plus +1 if you have a
correlation of +1 you have two stocks
that move in perfect sync if you have a
correlation of minus one one day book
moving perfect thing when in opposite
directions in this case the correlation
is plus point two all now let's do some
magic let's assume that you put half
your money in stock one and half your
money in stock two and ask you what the
standard deviation of that portfolio is
going to be your first reaction might be
that's easy stock why does a standard
deviation of 10 percent stock two as a
standard deviation of 15 percent if I
put half a money meets it should fall
right down the middle twelve and a half
percent and you'd be wrong and here's
why the standard deviation of the
portfolio will reflect the weights you
have on the two stocks wait no and stock
1 and stock do but it'll also reflect
how they move together so if you look at
the equation for the standard deviation
it's a little messy because you got the
weights and the squared but he takes the
net effect of that correlation what you
get as this as the standard deviation
off the combined portfolio 5050 is
magical it's magical
because its standard deviation is only
9.81% you said what do you mean only
9.81% I've combined two stocks which
have higher standard deviation and I've
ended up with the standard deviation
lower than either of those stocks that
is the magic of diversification now if
you want to do a what-if try making the
correlation one see what happens and
you're going to see that if you make the
correlation 1 the standard deviation of
the portfolio will end up at 12 and a
half percent the lower I make my
standard in the correlation the grade
and the benefit of diversification in
fact if I make the correlation negative
you're going to see the benefit become
even larger now this is the basis for
diversification and you can extend it
from so basically this was for two
assets you can extend it to three to
four there's a there's a mechanical
challenge you're gonna face because as
the number of assets goes from two to
three you now I have to calculate the
correlation between one in between asset
1 and asset 2 as 1 and 3 and 2 or 3
there are three core
as you go to for you what you're going
to see is the number of correlations is
going to start increasing exponentially
as you go from two to three to four to
five to a hundred strokes you can still
do it a computer can do it but here's
what you're also going to discover as
you keep adding stocks to your portfolio
as you go from two to three to four to
five the marginal benefit of adding the
next dog will start to get smaller and
smaller their benefit of adding the
fifty first stock to your portfolio will
be smaller than the benefit of the
second stock was or the benefit of the
eleventh stock was the marginal benefits
will get smaller they will never
disappear they will never drop below
zero but they will get smaller and
smaller and here's where finance makes
its first introduction the notion that
diversification is a good thing is
age-old remember the old problems don't
put all your eggs in one basket finance
introduces the notion of a marginal
investor and this is particularly in the
continent context of a publicly traded
company with thousands of potential
investors holding its shares the
marginal investor in accompanies the
investor who sets prices who has an
influence in prices and to be able to
influence prices think of what you need
you need to own a lot of shares if I
want a thousand shares an apple my
buying or selling Apple has no effect on
its pricing you need to own a lot of
shares and you need to trade those
shares
so marginal investor in the company if
somebody owns a lot of stock in the
company and trades or shares since you
need to trade the shares it means that
the biggest invest in a company might
not be the module investor so Larry
Ellison might be the largest stockholder
in Oracle he owns twenty percent plus of
the company but he is not the marginal
investor because he doesn't trade those
shares and I think so what if you look
at most companies even mid cap companies
even small companies you look at the
kinds of investors who own a lot of
shares and trade those shares those
investors tend to be institutional
investors and in finance we make the
assumption that the marginal investors
in most publicly traded companies are
diversified investors you think what
does that change remember what we just
said well as you diversify the way you
think about res changes because the risk
of a stock then
the risk that it adds to your portfolio
in fact when you look at the very first
risk and return model that acquired
dominance of Finance a capital asset
pricing model it's built on the
presumption that there are no
transactions cost and then you can't
pick stocks and if I make those two
assumptions you will never stop
diversifying in fact by the time you're
done you will note every single traded
acid in the market in your portfolio we
called it the market portfolio it sounds
absurd but without transactions caused
and without having some counterweight
remember the benefit to diversification
continues to be positive even for the
41st died without the 40,000 plus one
stock that you put in so that portfolio
it will include every single traded ass
you think so what in the capital asset
pricing model once you've come to the
conclusion that you should diversify it
should hold the market put for you the
risk of an asset then becomes the risk
that it adds to that market portfolio in
fact in the capital asset pricing model
when you look at the cross investors
you're saying where would I show
different degrees of risk aversion my
neighbor wants to take no risk I want to
take some risk my next-door neighbor
wants to take even more is if we all
hold the market portfolio what's going
to set us apart the answer is very
simply how much money you put into the
market portfolio and how much you leave
in a riskless investment your neighbor
once take no risk will put all of this
his or her money in the riskless asset
you might put half your money in the
market portfolio think of it as a
gigantic index front of every traded
acid and half of it of the riskless
asset your next-door neighbor once take
even more risk might put all his or her
money into the market portfolio and the
neighbor next to him or her who wants
take even more risk you know how their
take risks they would go out and borrow
money and buy the same market portfolio
we all will end up holding only two
assets a riskless asset and this
gigantic index fund of every traded
risky ass in the world that we call the
market portfolio it changes the way we
think about risk because no one asked
you how risky a stock is Disney Tesla
you name the company I'm going to
measure that risk by the risk it
it's to the market portfolio because
that's what I own and statistically I'm
gonna capture that risk with how the
stock moves with the market profile we
can we call this the covariance but it's
very very close relationship the
correlation we talk to line so the more
an asset Co varies with the market the
riskier it becomes and we standardize
this covariance by dividing by the
variances market simply because we want
to standardize number the covariance by
itself is there a number like 37 percent
45 percent single is that high is that
low we divide every covariance by the
variance of the market when we do that
we end up with the beta for a stock or a
beta for NASA and in the capital asset
pricing model that becomes your measure
of the risk of an asset and in fact if
you buy into all of the assumptions you
made in the capital asset pricing model
the beta then becomes a measure of the
risk in an asset at risk in an
investment and your expected return can
then be written as a risk-free rate
that's what you would demand for a
guaranteed investment plus a risk
premium that's a function of two things
the beta of the investment which is the
standardized measure of risk added to a
portfolio and the risk premium you
demand for an average risk investment
that becomes your expected return
magical right but think about all the
baggage you had to carry along the way
the cap M is built on some very very
strong assumptions it does give us this
great model or all you need is one
number a beta to capture the risk of a
stall but people have always known its
limitations and they've tried to adjust
adjust for them the early versions of
the cap I'm just trying to modify
assumptions and brought in taxes or
transactions cause of what would happen
in the model later versions they
extended the cabin in what way remember
in the cap M the fundamental intuition
is that you get rewarded only for risk
you cannot diversify away but we capture
that exposure to that risk with one
number of beta so in the extended
versions especially the first version of
the extended version which is called the
arbitrage pricing model you allowed for
multiple sources of market risk we're
still staying with the market risk on
sub risk you cannot diversify but now a
multiple sources in the beta against
each
the weakness of the arbitrage pricing
model is those multiple market risk
factors didn't have names there was
statistical factors were called factor 1
factor 2 factor 3 etc in later versions
of these much multi-factor models you
put macroeconomic names of the factors
level of interest rates term structure
essentially you're building an expanded
version of what you had in the cap M
allowing for betas against different
market risk factors in the last 25 years
as we've had access to more data there's
a third approach that's been tried which
I call which I not roughly called proxy
models in a proxy model here's what you
do you look for characteristics of
companies that have earned high returns
in the past so for instance if you look
at the last 50 60 70 years of returns
you find that small market cap companies
earn higher returns and large market cap
companies then you make a leap of faith
you then argue that small companies must
be riskier than larger companies now do
you see why I call these proxy models
you're letting market capitalization of
the company stand in as a proxy for risk
in the last 25 years as we've done
through the data we've been able to find
more and more proxies so when you look
at risk and return models in finance
you're either going to see the cap M
you're going to see a modified version
the Kappa and extended version of the
cap I'm a proxy model or some
combination in fact you could see a cap
that the traditional cap em with the
market cap proxy for risk thrown in as
well every risk and return model in
finance so it's born from that initial
foray into the mean variance framework
so here's the bottom line when you look
across these risk and return models and
your eyes glaze over because you get
caught up in the statistic evaders
here's what I want you to remember not
all risks come so when you invest in an
asset and you're exposed to risk don't
get expect to get rewarded for all that
risk because as long as there are
marginal investors in that stock who
price the stock based on a different
perception of risk you have to play
their game that's why when we value
companies we don't look at risk through
our own eyes we look at risk through the
eyes of the marginal investor because
they're the ones who set prices and to
the extent that those
and investors have diversified we use
risk measures that reflect the
versification so the fact that you and I
might not be diversified doesn't mean we
can use risk and return models that
reflect absence of diversification
because there are marginal investors out
there will diversify and the
diversification effect does mean that
the risk we focus on that we bring into
our risk measures and our risk premiums
might be only a portion of the risk you
see in an investment it's a risk that
you cannot diversify away now this page
has a lot of stuff in it but you get a
chance go through it it actually looks
at how our thinking on risk is evolved
through time because I until the 1500s
we didn't even have a measure we didn't
have probabilities without properties
you can't even start thinking my dress
so the starting point for the way we
think about risk goes back to the first
measures of probability which then fed
into insurance and then insurance fed
into price variance and the financial
markets gave us ratings and then you had
variances of measure of risk
many of the Markowitz revolution that's
the 1950s where Finance was born where
the key insight was that you don't get
rewarded for all the risk you get
exposed to because you can diversify
away some of that risk and then in the
last 30 or 40 years the availability of
data has allowed us to expand these
models to bring in multi-factor models
and proxy models but in one pages of the
history of how we've thought about risk
in finance so risk matters measuring
risk is key we have to make assumptions
and some of those assumptions might make
you uncomfortable to measure risk but
without a measure of risk we're going to
be lost in finance